it's time for the launch in kona scope a
television journal of the important
issues of the hour brought to you every
Monday Wednesday and Friday a
presentation of the lawn gene which nor
watch company maker of launching the
world's most honored watch and wit nor
distinguished companion to the world
honored lon gene good evening this is
frank night may I introduce our
co-editors for this edition of the lawn
gene chrono scope from the CBS
television news staff Larry loser and
Winston brunette our distinguished guest
for this evening is the honorable Joseph
R Farrington congressional delegate from
Hawaii mr. Farrington this is a great
time of the year here on the mainland to
be talking about sunny Hawaii but i
wonder if you as the congressional
delegate from hawaii would refresh our
memories a bit about what she referred
to as the paradise of the Pacific Hawaii
is situated about 2,400 miles south west
of San Francisco it is just inside of
the tropics and in the pathway of the
trade winds and that explains the very
beautiful climate that we enjoy in
Hawaii in land area it has something
over 6,000 square miles that's about
equal to Connecticut and Rhode Island
and a consists of eight main islands
which are spread over a distance of
about 350 miles the islands are
geologically rather new there a volcanic
origin and because of relatively
speaking recent origin we don't have any
minerals we just have a very fertile
soil and a very fine climate as a two
great resources well mr. Farrington what
is the present status of the Hawaiian
statehood bill and what are its
prospects at this session of Congress
would you say the bill to admit Hawaii
Union as a state was passed
by the house in the last session and is
now pending before the Senate Committee
on interior and insular affairs the
latter committee began hearings last May
and continued them through the summer
and concluded them only last Friday the
committee incidentally was to meet this
morning but there was a heavy snowfall
in Washington and so they postponed the
meeting to tomorrow morning and at that
time they will determine just what the
procedure will be this is the time of
decision on the whole and statehood
legislation well you think it's possible
that Hawaii might become a state during
this next second session at 83rd
Congress I hope that it becomes estate
and I think the prospects for winning
statehood are far better than ever
before in fact they're very good the
president you'll recall in the state of
the union message asked for the
enactment of the Hawaiian statehood bill
and the leadership of the of the Senate
has placed it among the first three
measures to be considered mr. Perron can
I ask would there be any advantages to
us in the United States or to Hawaii
itself if she did become a state
advantages to of the United States are
very very marked in my opinion it will
bring the people of Hawaii much closer
to the people of the states and will
constitute the final step in the
integration of the life of what is
really our Western outpost with the rest
of the continent country we're closely
integrated economically spiritually so
to speak and in every way except
politically this is the final a step it
will enhance our position from a defense
a standpoint because it will give notice
to the people of the world and
particularly to the Pacific that the
United States is not retreating beyond
Hawaii who may I ask is a Hawaii
defensible we all remember Pearl Harbor
of course I don't think there's any
question about that and I think that
we're coming back to the thinking that
existed prior to the war that there is a
part that we have in Hawaii a primary
base
we have of course a perimeter of of
Defense outposts a far ahead in the
Pacific as everyone knows but that
hasn't at all weakened at the importance
of Hawaiian on the contrary is
strengthened it that was very well
demonstrated during the Korean the
conflict when the necessity of keeping
the sea and air lanes open between the
states in Korea well mr. Farrington
would would statehood for Hawaii enhance
our political position in Asia I don't
think there's any question about it and
that offers one of the greatest reasons
for the admission of Hawaii to the Union
as a state the people of Hawaii are for
the most part American citizens I think
today that probably less than ten
percent of them are aliens but they're
American citizens whose parents came
there from in large part from the Far
East there are more people in Hawaii of
a Japanese origin Chinese origin
Filipino origin and Korean origin and
the rest of the country combined and
they have been United in the American
tradition and intensely loyal to this
country and their parents and relatives
in their home countries are watching to
see whether the United States will
fulfill the promise of statehood in
order to that would give them the same
status of every other merit of every
other American mr. Farrington do you
think the people of Hawaii would be
greatly disappointed if they were not to
get statehood at this time and would
that have political effects might if I
may say so might they go democratic
there's no question that they would be
very greatly disappointed being a
Republican I trust that they won't turn
to the Democratic a party by way of
expressing their their disappointment I
think that you can't do what you're not
likely to expect any immediate ill
effects of the failure that statehood
legislation but in the long run it will
do an
reparable amount of damage to one of the
great experiments in American democracy
because the only alternative to
statehood for Hawaii is colonial and we
know from the record of recent years
that ultimately colonialism holds the
seeds of its own destruction mr.
Farrington how do the people of Hawaii
feel right now about the prospects for
statehood are they pessimistic or
optimistic after the long history of
fighting for it they they are they're
very hopeful but underlying that is an
element of skepticism they're waiting
very watchful eye so to speak mr.
Farrington there seems to be criticism
from both sides of the political
spectrum against Hawaiian statehood and
one of the criticisms I've heard is that
to make Hawaii into a state would be
turning over too much control to the
five great missionary families who
founded it then there are other critics
who contend that it might be giving
control to the longshoremen and we're
Houseman's Union which I believe was
expelled from the cios that's regret of
course those two elements in the
population represent the two extremes
the so-called big five who are the
factors that represent the basic
agricultural industries represent the
represent management the leadership
incidentally the influences that have
effectively develop the resources of the
islands on the other hand the
International where husbands and long
shoreman's union to represent an
extremely militant Union and one whose
leadership has been described as
communist and whose leader of course
high bridges has been tried on charges
resulting out of his alleged communism
Oh mr. Farrington since the bulk of
Hawaii's population is of mixed race as
I remember wouldn't the Senators and
Representatives who would represent
Hawaii in our Congress reflect that
mixed population I
that's all altogether possible as that's
what has happened in our legislature and
in our government generally for 20 years
for instance Hawaii was represented by
French Jonah Kuhio Kalanianaole who was
a hawaiian prince the present governor
of the territory for why Sammy widely
king is very proud of the fact that he
is 18 Hawaiian descended on the one side
from the scratch sea captain and on the
other side from a family of Hawaiian
Chiefs mr. Farrington you said earlier
you were quite optimistic with regard to
passage of the statehood bill at this
session what basis do you have for being
especially optimistic this year there's
several reasons one of them and I'd say
this is the primary reason is that the
administration and the leadership of
Congress is strongly committed to the
enactment of that legislation in this
session of Congress it was promised in
the Republican and Democratic platforms
of 1952 and another reason for it is the
rising tide of public sentiment in favor
of statehood for Hawaii the last gallup
poll for instance shows that
seventy-eight percent of the people of
the country a favour statehood for
hawaii i think the force of public
opinion will inevitably make Hawaii a
state of the union mr. Farrington I'd
like to bring up just another point in
regard any objections to away in
statehood and that is that there is some
fear in the ourself that this might make
precedence against segregation is that
right no I don't think so I I think that
attitude of the people of Hawaii towards
a great race is in the traditional
American pattern as distinguished from
that in those areas of the country where
they do a practice segregation we do not
have segregation Hawaii on the other
hand I want to say this that we in Hawai
believe the problem of race should be
dealt with on a local basis and that the
people of who I should be allowed to
work out
program themselves and the other than
the people in other parts of the country
should do likewise it's a problem that
has got to be met by education and
social adjustment rather than by law we
ask that our position be respected and
within that regard and we respect the
position of others also thank you very
much mr. faction it's a great pleasure
to have you here in studio tonight the
opinions that you've heard our speakers
express tonight have been entirely their
own the editorial board for this edition
of the lawn gene Cronus cope was Larry
lesser and Winston Burdette our
distinguished guest was the Honorable
Joseph R Farrington congressional
delegate from Hawaii